regardez les gains pour les libéraux
l'atlantique +3 terre-neuve +9 au
nouveau brunswick plus 7 en nouvelle
écosse est plus un à l'île du prince
édouard et c'est l'histoire
opposé pour les conservateurs - 1 - 8.4
moyens être 21h40 radio canada prévoit
que le prochain gouvernement sera formé
par le parti libéral
22h37 radio canada que prévoit que le
gouvernement libéral sera bel et bien
majoritaires
ce n'est pas moi qui a fait l'histoire
ce soir c'est vous pendant les dernières
neuf années et demi j'ai eu l'honneur
incroyable de servir comme votre premier
ministre la population canadienne a élu
un gouvernement libéral
un résultat que nous acceptons sans
aucune hésitation et les canadiens ont
demandé aux intérêts de continuer d'être
porteurs de l'espoir et de l'optimisme
qui caractérise notre parti uzi rouge
c'est pour avoir les genoux au brassus